okay well I did not get the job in New
York but I got the real prize domestic
bliss Jan made me breakfast this morning
well she bought the milk it's soy this
is why I do it that's what I have to
come home to she probably won't be up
for a few hours this is going to be a
very good year very good
Jan is at home Jim is back my protege
Ryan is a corporate good stuff
Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales
team I feel very blessed I'm going in
why don't worry I have a card add-on
that I could see that but yeah
April document this watch you any
fact-finding mission is to get right
into the battle zone you know it's like
George Bush when he flew over New
Orleans or Richard Nixon when he went to
China to see what the Chinese were up to
no Leslie hold on April's gonna get some
photos for the website you this beast oh
don't move around as much all right we
got binocs camera night-vision goggles
computer and baby basketball oh my god I
love that my whole problem with
basketball was big ball tiny hands tiny
ball problem solved
OOP me ready ooping one two three
that look as cool as I thought how cool
did it feel at least once a year I like
to bring in some of my Kevin's famous
chili the trick is to undercook the
onions everybody is going to get to know
each other in the pot I'm serious about
this stuff I'm up the night before
pressing garlic and dicing whole
Tomatoes I toast my own ancho chiles
it's a recipe passed down from Malone's
for generations it's probably the thing
I do best
my leg my leg
you broke my other leg oh this was
supposed to be a safe event nothing to
see here
except for the bone all sticking out of
the leg Jim come on tough day Jim oh my
god when we can't sit on him he took
another gig in Eagleton library oh
that's really the worst place I can
imagine okay guys we're not giving up on
this he's not the only musician in town
Andy yeah I don't know let's see I don't
really feel like playing right now
Please Please Please Please Please
Please I don't even have children's
songs my last song I wrote was called
sex hair well just take the word sex and
change it to pickle pickle you've got
pickle here baby and you got it from me
sounds like it's about sex
I'm in I gotta grab my guitar for my
house I'll be back shortly yeah see guys
we have a solution and and the good news
is there's always a solution
and your motives are pure heads up
there's our perp looking home herpy just
perp in his way down perp street take a
picture get one second my slides really
unflattering for his complexion it
doesn't have to be perfect Tom Olsen is
a bad dude he's held up for electronic
stores at gunpoint and I wish you hadn't
read that Annie Leibowitz book we're
calling it a book there's a visual
journey you're probably that guy should
shoot this in common set up like a light
yes shoot color why have you been
shooting black and white where's he
going now what
damnit NYPD freak
[Music]
you strapped
my birthday wish finally came true
[Applause]
pam-pam hey what happened now don't you
a goodbye poem it's really long I have
to go to my office could you just please
wait till I go get it I should really
get going
oh okay okay um
the last word is piteous seagulls I'm
sure it was really a lot I took away
from other poems told me when you get in
okay all right cool I know Mike
hey Anne are you still nurse or did they
fire you because you slept with all the
doctors you want to try that again
hey Anne are you so nurse because Andy's
not feeling well
What's Wrong Andy just got a headache
and I'm seeing double and I got a song
stuck in my head and my teeth hurt
also I'm hungry okay well some of those
things are symptoms and some of them are
just being a person did you hit your
head no oh yes technically I did smash
my head area into the wall area yeah he
was hanging up his gold record oh my god
are you okay yeah I'm good
ah trying to pick the lock El Capitan
that'll take at least three minutes by
which time I will have his this plaque
somewhere you will never find it
[Music]
voila of course you could break the
window but you would never knowingly
destroy government property would you
read that one Tina
Oh Gina
are you okay it's go I'm fine
ain't nothing totally girl you again how
can we not watch this what happened - do
not mock we're not mocking we're
watching that one habitable you lead -
mocking sister tape with me falling yes
PvdA start on the song quick trust me
I've done this guys Michael can't handle
this and as your boss I'm saying we're
not watching it no it's okay watch it
you can't fire all of you what are you
doing it's alright I can handle it no I
am a grown-up Jin did you see that see
what wait Oscar yes you're right - stop
it thank you dejected you let Michael
fall in play it again
purposefully leaned away and let you
fall man I think when I started to see
you go in I think I just froze I don't
think you froze to kill her new dance
move
do you want to turn your house no I
didn't ask you would you like to talk
Judis Jim is my enemy but it turns out
that Jim is also his own worst enemy and
the enemy of my enemy is my friend
so Jim is actually my friend but because
he is his own worst enemy the enemy of
my friend is my enemy
so actually Jim is my enemy but you know
like when you go to the ATM and you get
money is there an actual guy standing
behind the wall who slides dollar bills
in there no yeah this robots Oh actually
you know what I do have a serious
question in a movie predator can you rub
any kind of mud on yourself
to prevent predator from seeing you with
his thermal heat signature sight or is
it oh that sucks
are you hurt oh no all good all good
oops except for my mouth oh whoa
five-second rule nope
thank you guys I thought of a funny
response to Terry's text from earlier
would you want to take my look for hit
Send Charles you've trained for this
moment okay we trust you just send it
come here good job all right I'm gonna
do it
why do
you